Before he got sick, he pictured the world this way. There are the people who are healthy, like him, and people who are sick, other people. And unconsciously, as we all do, he drew a line between the two groups, the two countries. Then when Paul Cowan was diagnosed with leukemia in 1987, he was struck with the fact that these are not, of course, two different populations, the sick and the healthy. Instead he wrote, "The world is composed of the sick and the not yet sick."
在生病之前，他眼中的世界是这样的：有一些人是健康的，像他一样；而另一些人是生病的，是“其他人”。我们都会下意识地在两类人、两个国家之间划出一道界限。1987年，保罗·考恩被诊断出患有白血病，他猛然意识到，病人与健康人并非两个完全不同的群体。相反，正如他所写的那样：“世界由两种人组成，一种是病人，另一种是尚未生病的人。”
He published an account of his illness in The Village Voice. "I want to describe some of what I've seen during the voyage I've made, the journey from being a person who took his health for granted to one who's trying to survive a life-threatening illness. I want to chart some of this wilderness for others who will be here one day." Well, that's the mission of today's radio program, because all of us, you and me both, if we're lucky, if we don't die when we're young, this is where we're heading, heart disease, cancer. Men have a one in two lifetime chance of getting cancer. For women, it's one in three. If you're a man hearing the sound of my voice right now, I want you to look at yourself for a moment. It's you or me, man. Odds are one of us will get it. Or we'll both get it. Two other guys will go off scot-free.
他在《乡村之声》上发表了关于自己病情的记录。“我想要描述我在旅途中所见的部分景象，这是一段从健康人转变为试图在危及生命的疾病中求生者的旅程。我想为未来也将踏上这条路的人们绘制一张地图。”嗯，这就是今天这期广播节目的使命。因为我们所有人，你和我，如果我们足够幸运，如果我们不在年轻时离世，我们最终都将走向那里——心脏病、癌症。男性一生中患癌的概率是二分之一，女性是三分之一。如果你是一位正在听我节目的男士，我希望你审视一下自己。伙计，这事关你我。按概率算，我们中总有一个人会患病，或者我们两个都会患病，而其他两个家伙可能会侥幸逃脱。
So let us chart this terrain where, if we all live long enough, we will be entering. Cowan writes, "During the past five months, I've learned that there's a land of the sick. When you receive a passport, an unwelcome diagnosis, you learn that the land has its own language-- medical terminology-- its own geography-- hospitals, outpatient clinics, blood testing labs, doctors' offices-- its own citizens-- other sick people-- its own pantheon of heroes and authority figures-- doctors, medical researchers, hospital administrators-- its own calendar dictated by the changes in one's body or by the results of medical tests."
那么，让我们来描绘一下这片领域，如果我们活得足够久，终将踏入这片土地。考恩写道：“在过去的五个月里，我了解到有一个‘病人国度’。当你拿到护照——一份不受欢迎的诊断书时，你就会发现这个国度有自己的语言——医学术语；有自己的地理环境——医院、门诊、验血实验室、医生办公室；有自己的公民——其他病人；有自己的英雄和权威人物殿堂——医生、医学研究人员、医院管理者；还有由身体变化或医疗检查结果所决定的自己的历法。”
When you're well, it's hard to remember what it's like to be sick. And after just a brief time in the hospital, Cowan found it hard to remember what it was like for him just weeks before to be active and self-sufficient. His picture of himself changed. He struggled to retain ties to the land of the healthy, to see himself as an exile who would return one day. But he did not return.
当你健康时，很难记起生病是什么感觉。而在医院待了一小段时间后，考恩发现自己很难回想起仅仅几周前那个活力充沛、自给自足的自己是什么模样。他对自己形象的认知改变了。他挣扎着想与“健康国度”保持联系，想把自己看作一个终将归来的流亡者。但他没能归来。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks, of course, we bring you a variety of different stories on some theme. Today we bring you just one story about one person's journey from the world of healthy people into the world of sick ones. Today on our program, Scenes from a Transplant.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和公共广播国际台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。通常每周，我们都会围绕某个主题带给大家各种不同的故事。今天，我们只带来一个故事，讲述一个人从健康人的世界进入病人世界的旅程。今天节目的主题是：移植的场景。
In 1995, Rebecca Perl had a new baby boy that she and her partner, Tom, named Griffin. She was a health science reporter with National Public Radio in Washington, D.C., where she'd just won a Peabody Award for an investigative series about the tobacco industry. She did a lot of stories about doctors and medicine. Then she was diagnosed with non-Hodgkin's lymphoma and entered the medical world as a patient. She had six months of radiation and chemotherapy. It didn't work. So in the winter of 1996, as a last attempt to save her life, she and Tom traveled from their home in Maryland to Omaha, Nebraska, to the University of Nebraska Medical Center for a bone marrow transplant and another round of chemotherapy, a round of chemotherapy as much as 10 times stronger than the original. Dan Collison, a friend of theirs and a radio producer, went with them, and he documented what happened. He also interviewed Rebecca a year later. This is her story.
1995年，丽贝卡·珀尔生下了一个男婴，她和伴侣汤姆给孩子取名为格里芬。她是华盛顿国家公共广播电台的健康科学记者，曾因关于烟草行业的调查报道系列而获得皮博迪奖。她做过很多关于医生和医学的报道。后来，她被诊断出患有非霍奇金淋巴瘤，并作为一名病人进入了医疗世界。她经历了六个月的放疗和化疗，但没有奏效。因此，在1996年冬天，作为挽救生命的最后尝试，她和汤姆从马里兰州的家中前往内布拉斯加州奥马哈的内布拉斯加大学医学中心，接受骨髓移植和另一轮化疗，这轮化疗的强度比之前的强了整整10倍。他们的朋友、广播制作人丹·科利森陪同他们前往，记录下了发生的一切。一年后，他还采访了丽贝卡。这就是她的故事。
Daddy and Dan and I are going away, Griffy, for a little. We're going on a trip. You're going to stay with Grandpa and Grandma, with Pop-Pop and Grandma, OK?
爸爸、丹和我得走一会儿，格里芬，我们要去旅行。你要和爷爷奶奶，和外公外婆待在一起，好吗？
Sometimes I worry that Griffin's going to fall in love with some woman who just lays in bed all the time because that's what he sees his mother doing in the first two years of his life. I mean, he's going to fall in love with some woman who lies in bed and eats bonbons or something, or reads or something, because that seems to be what I'm turning into is this person who lies in bed all the time. Or else I lie on the couch and read him books or something.
有时候我很担心格里芬以后会爱上一个整天躺在床上的女人，因为那是他生命前两年里看到的妈妈的样子。我的意思是，他会爱上一个只会躺在床上吃糖果、看书之类的女人，因为我似乎正在变成那样一个整天躺在床上的人。要么我就是躺在沙发上给他读书。
"Once there were three baby owls, Sarah, Percy, and Bill. They lived in a hole in the trunk of a tree with their mother owl. The hole had twigs and leaves and owl feathers in it. It was their house. One night they woke up and their mother owl was gone. 'Where's Mommy?' said Sarah. 'Oh, my goodness,' said Percy. 'I want my mommy,' said Bill."
“从前有三只猫头鹰宝宝，莎拉、珀西和比尔。它们和猫头鹰妈妈住在大树干的一个树洞里。洞里有树枝、树叶和羽毛，那是它们的家。一天晚上，它们醒来发现妈妈不见了。‘妈妈去哪儿了？’莎拉说。‘噢，天哪，’珀西说。‘我要妈妈，’比尔说。”
He really likes the owl book, and it makes him feel better that in the owl book, the mommy owl goes away but then she comes back. So I think he understands that. And lots of mothers go away on trips and go off for work for weeks at a time. And I've had to do that. Now the really bad one is I'm going to have to go away for a month or more. And he'll hopefully come visit. But still, it's going to be a really long time. I mean, it happens. And I guess the most important thing is that I get well so that he can have a mother.
他真的很喜欢这本猫头鹰的书，书里猫头鹰妈妈虽然离开了但最终会回来，这让他感觉好受些。我想他能理解这一点。很多妈妈因为工作原因会离开家几周，我也曾不得不这样做。现在最糟糕的是，我不得不离开一个月甚至更久。希望他能来看我。但那仍然是很长的一段时间。这种事总会发生。我想最重要的是我能好起来，这样他才能有个妈妈。
OK.
好的。
Bye bye, Griffy. We'll see you soon, OK? Bye bye. You stay with Grandpa and Mama, OK? Say bye bye.
再见，格里芬。我们很快就会见面的，好吗？再见。你要和爷爷奶奶在一起，好吗？说再见。
[SCREAMS]
[尖叫]
OK, OK. You go to Pop-Pop. Want to go to Pop-Pop?
好了，好了。你去外公那里。想去外公那吗？
No.
不要。
Yes. They have to go.
去吧，他们得走了。
No.
不要。
We'll see you soon.
我们很快会见面的。
You're going to go to the park with [? Marta. ?]
你要去公园，和[？玛塔？]在一起。
Look, Griffy. Bye-bye, Mommy.
看，格里芬。再见，妈妈。
Bye-bye.
再见。
Griffy, bye-bye, Daddy. Bye-bye.
格里芬，再见，爸爸。再见。
Bye, Griffy. You'll be OK. Bye-bye.
再见，格里芬。你会没事的。再见。
They're coming back. They're coming back. Don't cry.
他们会回来的。他们会回来的。别哭。
[CRYING] Dada.
[哭泣] 爸爸。
There are at least three reasons why I was supposed to be exempt from getting seriously sick. First, Tom, my partner of 10 years and the father of our son, Griffin, had a kidney transplant in 1988, so he's supposed to be the one with the health problems in our family. If I ever envisioned myself in a hospital, it was standing at his bedside. Second, about six years ago, my older brother Josh was diagnosed with leukemia. And I don't think anyone expected two serious cancer patients in our family. Third, I'm a health reporter, and though my focus has always been on patients and how they're affected by our health care system, I never thought I would end up as one of these people.
我本该免于重病，至少有三个理由。首先，和我相伴10年、格里芬的父亲汤姆，在1988年接受过肾移植，所以我们家生病的人应该是他。如果我曾设想过自己出现在医院，那也是站在他的病床边。其次，大约六年前，我的哥哥乔希被诊断出白血病。我想没人会想到家里会有两个严重的癌症病人。第三，我是一名健康记者，虽然我一直关注的是病人以及他们如何受到医疗系统的影响，但我从未想过自己最终会成为他们中的一员。
And they're off on a big road trip. You got your warm coat?
他们开始了一场大公路旅行。你带上暖和的外套了吗？
Yeah.
带了。
OK, and we got lots of turkey sandwiches.
好的，我们准备了很多火鸡三明治。
Maybe it was a little crazy to drive all the way to Omaha in the dead of winter, but I hate to fly, and Tom likes road trips. I think we were determined to make the trip fun. Driving would give us a sense of where we were going. Plus, we got to stop at The Waffle House.
在寒冬腊月开车去奥马哈可能有点疯狂，但我讨厌飞行，而汤姆喜欢公路旅行。我想我们决心让这次旅行变得有趣。开车会让我们对行程有更清晰的感受。此外，我们还可以顺路去华夫饼屋。
We're in the bathroom of The Waffle House. Did you lock the door?
我们在华夫饼屋的洗手间里。你锁门了吗？
Yeah.
锁了。
And I'm going to give myself an injection of Neupogen. It's just like being a heroine addict.
我要给自己注射纽波根（Neupogen）。这感觉就像是个海洛因成瘾者。
For me, it was the worst part, having to give myself shots. For one thing, it hurt. And it was a symbol of what I was going through.
对我来说，这是最糟糕的部分，不得不给自己打针。首先，这很疼。而且，这象征着我正在经历的一切。
And then the funnest part is you jab it into your leg like so. And then you just push it in. And sometimes it hurts, and sometimes it doesn't. It sort of depends on where you get it in the leg. Voila. And that's it. I used to do it at home when I had to do it for like 10 days. I'd do it at like 7:25, right before Seinfeld . So if it took me more than five minutes to do it, I'd miss Seinfeld . So I'd hurry myself along. Now I'm doing it right before I get to eat at Waffle House. So I give myself a treat afterwards.
最“有趣”的部分是你把它扎进腿里，就这样。然后推进去。有时会疼，有时不会，这取决于你扎在哪里。好了，就是这样。以前在家时我要连打10天，我会在7点25分，也就是《宋飞正传》开始前打。如果超过五分钟，我就会错过节目，所以我得快点。现在我准备在华夫饼屋吃东西前打，这样之后还能给自己点个甜点作为奖励。
BLT on wheat.
全麦BLT三明治。
Mmm! Waffle House. Chicken melt. Oh, boy.
嗯！华夫饼屋，鸡肉熔岩三明治。噢，天呐。
December 1. After three days on the road, we make it to Omaha.
12月1日。经过三天的路程，我们到达了奥马哈。
Have a seat, and we'll be with you in just a minute, OK?
请坐，我们马上就来，好吗？
I'm feeling pretty rotten from the ill effects of my final round of chemotherapy back in Washington. They messed up at the hospital. The line that was supposed to administer the chemo wasn't in the right place, so the drugs went into my belly instead of my bloodstream. Because of this, my bladder hurts and I'm tired. And I'm about to embark on a nasty, exhausting journey. I feel as if I need more strength, but here we go.
我在华盛顿接受最后一轮化疗后的不良反应让我感觉很糟糕。医院搞砸了。负责输送化疗药的管子没放对位置，所以药物流进了我的腹部而不是血液里。正因如此，我的膀胱很疼，我很累。而我即将踏上一段恶劣、令人筋疲力尽的旅程。我觉得我需要更多力量，但我们只能出发了。
We're going to do your EKG right in this room.
我们要在这个房间为你做心电图。
OK.
好的。
The first week in Omaha felt like boot camp. I shuffled from one test to another.
在奥马哈的第一周感觉就像新兵训练营。我从一个检查室晃到另一个。
Three more seconds. Keep going. A couple more breaths. Stop. Good. Good test.
再坚持三秒。继续。再吸气。停。好。检查做得不错。
Endless poking and prodding.
无尽的扎针和检查。
OK, Rebecca, you're going to feel a poke and a burn. This is the numbing medication.
好了，丽贝卡，你会感觉到一点扎刺和烧灼感。这是麻醉药。
There's a tiny little poke. I'm sorry. Your skin's a tiny bit tough.
有一点小刺痛。抱歉，你的皮肤有点硬。
One more to go after this, honey. It's not bothering you, is it? OK.
这之后还有一个，亲爱的。这没让你感到不适吧？好了。
I'm just tired of being poked and prodded and pricked and achy and tired. This is supposed to be the easy time. I can't imagine it being any worse.
我真的厌倦了被扎、被碰、被刺，浑身酸痛且疲惫不堪。这应该还是最轻松的时候，我无法想象如果更严重会怎样。
Tomorrow-- don't eat or drink after midnight tonight. Tomorrow at 8 o'clock, you'll go down to the first floor of the hospital to special x-rays.
明天——今晚午夜后不要吃东西或喝水。明天8点，你要去医院一楼拍特殊X光片。
Kathy Byar was my nurse coordinator. She seemed more interested in keeping me on schedule than in what I was going through. We called her my drill sergeant.
凯西·拜尔是我的护士协调员。她似乎更关心我是不是按时完成日程，而不是我的感受。我们叫她“魔鬼教官”。
You know, I would imagine it does feel like that because you lose that control. All of a sudden, you're coming to a strange institution. They're telling you when, where, and what to do. And as a person that's young, independent, used to having her own kind of control, it's very frustrating.
你知道，我可以想象那种感觉，因为你失去了控制权。突然间，你来到一个陌生的地方。他们告诉你何时、何地、该做什么。对于一个年轻、独立，习惯了自我掌控的人来说，这非常令人沮丧。
I'm a medical reporter, so I was used to asking a lot of questions. And maybe they just weren't used to pushy New Yorkers in Omaha.
我是一名医疗记者，习惯了问很多问题。也许他们不习惯奥马哈来个难搞的纽约人。
You've got to get me on a later schedule. I'm too exhausted.
你得帮我把日程排得晚一点。我太累了。
And I didn't like Kathy's cheerleading.
而且我不喜欢凯西那种啦啦队式的鼓励。
Positive attitude. Positive attitude. You're not going to feel sick.
保持积极态度。保持积极态度。你不会觉得难受的。
I just wasn't in the mood, you know? I'd been through a lot already. And I was tired. I remember she would say, positive attitude, positive attitude. And I just felt like hell, you know? I had a positive attitude the first time around, and it didn't work. I mean, now I was going through something even worse. And it was hard for me to keep positive.
我只是没那个心情，你知道吗？我已经经历了很多。我很累。记得她常说“保持积极态度”，可我当时觉得糟透了。我第一次治疗时心态很积极，但没用。现在我正经历着更糟糕的事，很难保持积极。
You're not going to feel sick. Not going to get sick. Not going to get sick.
你不会觉得难受的。不会生病的。不会生病的。
One coping mechanism I did have was to act like a health reporter. I was obsessed with the numbers. It was really important for me to know the odds that the transplant would work. Those odds were about 50-50. So sometimes, sitting in a room with other patients, I couldn't help but think that only about half of us were going to make it. And this made it kind of hard to get close to people. But Graham and his family was an exception.
我的一种应对机制就是像个健康记者一样行事。我执着于数字。对我来说，知道移植成功的几率非常重要。几率大约是五五开。所以有时坐在病人中间，我不禁会想，我们中只有一半人能活下来。这让我很难与人亲近。但格雷厄姆和他的家人是个例外。
Hi, ?] I'm Graham [? Brazier. ?] I'm here for a bone marrow transplant because of multiple myeloma, which is a disease that was diagnosed in May of '96.
嗨，我是格雷厄姆·[？布拉泽尔？]。我来这里做骨髓移植，因为我患有多发性骨髓瘤，那是96年5月诊断出来的。
Graham was a young father facing worse odds than me.
格雷厄姆是一位年轻的父亲，面临着比我更糟的几率。
The latest statistics are that three years out from transplant, 35% are disease-free, as they call it.
最新的统计数据是，移植后三年，有35%的人不再受疾病困扰。
His wife, Lorraine, was playing the support role and caring for their 9-month-old redheaded son, Thomas. Even though I admired Lorraine for being able to be a mom there at the hospital and even though Thomas made me miss Griffin, I was glad Griff wasn't there. He was older than Thomas. He was nearly a year and a half. I was afraid that if he were there with me, he would understand too much. And I didn't want him to have to understand anything.
他的妻子洛林承担着支持者的角色，还要照顾他们9个月大的红发儿子托马斯。尽管我很敬佩洛林能在医院里做个称职的母亲，尽管托马斯让我想起格里芬，但我很庆幸格里芬不在那儿。他比托马斯大，快一岁半了。我担心如果他在身边，他会懂太多。而我不想让他不得不了解任何事。
Hi, Griffy! Hi, Griffy!
嗨，格里芬！嗨，格里芬！
So I settled for the occasional phone call.
所以我只能满足于偶尔打个电话。
Hey, Griffy, want me to sing "Macaroni"? I have a little pony. His name is Macaroni. He trots and trots and then he stops. My funny little pony, Macaroni. Do you like that song, Griffy?
嘿，格里芬，想让我唱《通心粉》吗？我有一匹小马，名叫通心粉。它哒哒哒地跑，然后停下。我可爱的小马，通心粉。你喜欢那首歌吗，格里芬？
I don't know. In a lot of ways, I guess I have kind of removed myself from him, because I know I have to go through this and do this. And it's sort of the last thing I have to do before I can really be with him for real or have the energy for him for real. So a lot of times I don't have the energy for him, and that makes it easier to kind of separate from him.
我不知道。在很多方面，我想我已经把自己和他隔开了，因为我知道我必须经历这些。这算是我在真正能和他在一起，或是真正有精力陪他之前最后要做的事。所以我常没有精力陪他，这让我更容易和他保持距离。
Griffy, I miss you. I'll see you soon. I love you. I love you, Griffy.
格里芬，我想你了。很快见。我爱你。我爱你，格里芬。
Breathe in. Hold your breath.
吸气。屏住呼吸。
December 10. We get some bad news. The CAT scan shows the most recent round of chemotherapy back in Washington hasn't shrunk the tumor nearly at all. Julie Vose is my doctor in Omaha.
12月10日。我们得到了一些坏消息。CT扫描显示，在华盛顿进行的最近一轮化疗几乎没能缩小肿瘤。朱莉·沃斯是我在奥马哈的医生。
Rebecca still has a mass found on her CT scan. So we're going to administer another cycle of salvage chemotherapy that's a slightly different type, to try and reduce that mass further down before she actually undergoes the transplant. And we've found in the past that this is the best way to try and have the best long-term outcome for patients.
丽贝卡的CT扫描显示仍有肿块。所以我们将进行另一轮不同类型的挽救性化疗，试图在移植前进一步缩小肿块。我们过去发现，这是为病人争取最佳长期结果的最佳方式。
The good news is I'm actually feeling much better. So that night, we celebrate.
好消息是我感觉好多了。所以那天晚上，我们庆祝了一下。
We're even out at a restaurant. Not just any restaurant, but a find of a restaurant, this Catfish Lodge here in Omaha, with the white albino catfish in the tank in the middle. I'm actually feeling good tonight. It's like a miracle. I haven't felt like this. I'm not, like, crying or in pain or something.
我们甚至去了餐厅。不是随便哪家餐厅，而是一家很特别的，位于奥马哈的鲶鱼小屋，中间的水箱里有白色的白化鲶鱼。我今晚感觉真不错。简直像奇迹。我没哭，也不疼。
Two days later, I begin the Omaha chemo.
两天后，我开始了奥马哈的化疗。
They give you four drugs, and one of them is blue. I kind of like the blue one, because it's just so startling. It looks like blue food coloring kind of color or like blueberry frozen popsicle melted.
他们用了四种药，其中一种是蓝色的。我挺喜欢蓝色的那个，因为它很显眼。看起来像食用色素或是融化的蓝莓冰棒。
And you said that you dressed accordingly today?
你说你今天特意穿了衣服配合它？
Yes, I wore my blue pants to go with the blue. My electric blue pants to go with the electric blue poison.
是的，我穿了蓝色裤子来搭配蓝色药物。我那条电光蓝裤子，为了搭配电光蓝毒药。
The American Cancer Society offers classes in how you can look better and feel better. And though it sounded hokey at the time, now I understand why they do this. Getting sick really played havoc with my body image. I felt as if my body had betrayed me like a separate person I couldn't trust. My sexual desire went out the window. I figured I wouldn't mind losing my hair because at least it wouldn't hurt. But looking at myself in the mirror was like looking at a Holocaust victim, all skin and bones. Actually, I've always been tiny and scrawny, but I never minded before. So I avoided mirrors and wore a hat even when the weather got warm. I did break down and let Tom style the little bit of fuzz that was still left on my head.
美国癌症协会提供“如何看起来更好、感觉更好”的课程。虽然当时听起来很老套，但现在我明白了他们为什么要这样做。生病确实让我的身体形象变得一团糟。我觉得身体背叛了我，像个我无法信任的陌生人。我的性欲完全消失了。我想掉头发我或许不介意，至少那不疼。但看着镜子里的自己就像看着大屠杀幸存者，皮包骨头。其实我一直很瘦小，但以前从不在意。所以我避开镜子，即使天气转暖也戴着帽子。我终于妥协，让汤姆修剪了我头上仅剩的那点绒毛。
This is the weapon. It's small but very effective. Let's see. I've got to do a little experimental swatch here.
这就是武器。很小但很有效。看看。我得在这里试验性地剪一下。
Don't be doing the top.
别剪头顶。
I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. Trust me. Just trust me.
我没剪。我没剪。相信我，相信我。
Those are famous last words.
那真是名言。
Breathe in. Hold your breath.
吸气。屏住呼吸。
I just had a CT scan. They're looking to compare the tumor in the chest to how it was in October, see if it's shrunk.
我刚做完CT扫描。他们要对比胸部的肿瘤和十月份相比是否缩小了。
Breathe.
呼吸。
The blue chemo hasn't shrunk the tumor either. So finally it's time to get on with the bone marrow transplant.
蓝色化疗也没有缩小肿瘤。所以终于到了进行骨髓移植的时候了。
I mean, it's discouraging that the tumor hasn't shrunk any. I was hoping it would shrink with these last bunch of chemos. I'm just anxious to get done. And I'm hoping it's really going to work. And I'm kind of wondering about what's the chances it's really going to work. They can't be as good as they would be if the tumor had shrunk a lot.
肿瘤没有缩小，这真令人沮丧。我本希望这几轮化疗能让它缩小的。我只是急着结束。我希望这真的有效。我还在想它真正成功的几率有多少。如果肿瘤缩得很小，成功率肯定会更高。
Is it OK if I go ahead and get your consent form signed today, so we're all ready to go when you're ready to go?
今天我可以让你签同意书吗？这样等你准备好时我们就能马上开始了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
OK.
好的。
The consent form is a reminder of what I'm in for. It lists all sorts of nasty things that could and sometimes do happen when you have a bone marrow transplant-- kidney failure, liver failure, heart failure.
同意书提醒着我将要面对的一切。它列出了骨髓移植可能导致的各种可怕后果——肾衰竭、肝衰竭、心力衰竭。
It sounds really scary, and that's because we have to put every little last thing in here that could possibly happen. That doesn't mean it's going to happen. But we have to let you know that's a rare possibility.
听起来很吓人，因为我们必须写下所有可能发生的小概率事件。但这不意味着一定会发生。我们只是必须告知你那是种罕见的可能性。
It didn't help to see the transplant patients who were a week or two ahead of me. They had just been where I was going, and they looked so weak shuffling into the clinic. But our friend Graham had his transplant two days ago, and he seems to be doing pretty well.
看到比我早一两周进行移植的病人并没让我感觉好受。他们刚刚经历了我将要经历的，看起来那么虚弱地晃进诊所。但我们的朋友格雷厄姆两天前做了移植，看起来还不错。
Everybody ?] seems to be different. And some people, I understand, end up on ventilators. The worst thing I experienced up there, apart from the nausea, was lockjaw. And that was just a strange sensation, the way your jaw freezes up and your tongue starts sucking down your throat.
每个人似乎都不一样。据我所知，有些人最终要用呼吸机。除了恶心之外，我在那儿经历的最糟糕的事是牙关紧闭。那是一种奇怪的感觉，你的下巴僵住，舌头开始往喉咙里缩。
People on the transplant unit seem to fall into two groups. There are the ones who get their chemo and get out, and there are the ones who get infections and end up on respirators. This winter, a lot of patients have gotten influenza. They're on respirators, and they're taking a long time to recover. There is a shortage of beds, so I wait, spending most of my time inside the clean, cozy apartment we have rented. I sit on the rose-covered couch and watch the sparrows out the window. It's very cold.
移植病房的人似乎分为两类。一类是做完化疗就能走的，另一类是感染了不得不上呼吸机的。这个冬天，很多病人患上了流感。他们带着呼吸机，恢复得很慢。床位短缺，所以我不得不等，把大部分时间花在我们租的那个干净舒适的公寓里。我坐在开满玫瑰花的沙发上，看窗外的麻雀。天气很冷。
WOW FM, Omaha-Council Bluffs. Good morning, I'm Mike Bradley. The Omaha metro area, as well as other areas in east central Nebraska, northern Nebraska, and all of southwest Iowa under a winter storm warning for blowing snow and dangerous wind chills, down to 65 to 70 below zero.
奥马哈-康瑟尔布拉夫斯WOW FM电台。早上好，我是迈克·布拉德利。奥马哈都市区，以及内布拉斯加州中东部、北部和爱荷华州西南部的大部分地区都处于冬季风暴预警下，会有吹雪和危险的寒风，体感温度低至零下65到70度。
As we wait, I'm thinking about what's going to happen. Even though they call it a bone marrow transplant, which conjures up images of long, dagger-like needles being jabbed into the spine, actually, they collect the bone marrow, or stem cells, from my blood with a contraption much like a dialysis machine. The machine borrows your blood, culls it for stem cells, and then gives it back. It's the stem cells that produce red cells, white cells, and platelets, all of which will be wiped out by the high doses of chemo. Dr. Ruth Kessinger pioneered the treatment in Omaha.
等待的时候，我在想接下来会发生什么。虽然叫骨髓移植，会让人联想到长长的针头扎进脊椎，但实际上，他们是从我的血液中通过类似透析机的装置采集骨髓或干细胞。机器借用你的血液，筛选出干细胞，然后把血还给你。正是干细胞产生了红细胞、白细胞和血小板，而这些都会被大剂量化疗消灭。露丝·凯辛格博士在奥马哈开创了这种疗法。
The machine empties the cells into a very important, special bag. We take the bag of cells to the laboratory. And in the laboratory, we freeze them in a liquid nitrogen freezer and save them there. Then the patient can go get his or her high-dose therapy. The high-dose therapy, of course, is intended to kill tumor cells. But the doses are so high that it also hurts the bone marrow. And that's the reason you need to give the stem cells back to the patient so they can grow a new bone marrow.
机器将细胞排入一个非常重要、特殊的袋子里。我们把那袋细胞送到实验室，在液氮冰箱里冻存起来。然后病人就可以去接受大剂量治疗了。大剂量治疗旨在杀死癌细胞，但药量太大也会损伤骨髓。所以需要把干细胞回输给病人，让他们长出新的骨髓。
So as soon as the high-dose therapy is finished, and hopefully the cancer is finished too-- it's been killed-- then we get the cells out of the freezer. We thaw them, and we simply inject them back into the bloodstream of the patient. And like a miracle, these stem cells know where to go. They home right to the empty bone marrow space and begin to grow.
因此，一旦大剂量治疗结束，希望癌症也被清除了，我们就把细胞从冰箱里拿出来。解冻后，简单地注射回病人的血液里。奇迹般的是，这些干细胞知道去哪儿。它们直接回到空置的骨髓空间开始生长。
Hi, can I help you?
嗨，有什么能帮你的吗？
Hi, I'm supposed to be admitted.
嗨，我应该办理入院手续。
Oh, OK. What's the name?
噢，好的。名字是？
Rebecca Perl.
丽贝卡·珀尔。
Perl?
珀尔？
I think of it kind of like a pregnancy, like having a child, like the birth. I mean, no one can tell you what it's going to be like. You kind of know it's going to be awful, or that's what a lot of people say. But nobody can really tell you what it's really going to be like, and everyone's experience is really different. And it's just sort of like, you don't have a choice. You're just going to do it. It's just going to happen. And I just sort of feel like with this it's the same thing. It's like this momentum, and it's just going to happen, and I'm going to do it. I mean, it's scary, but I'm just going to do it.
我觉得这有点像怀孕，生孩子的过程。我的意思是，没人能告诉你那是什么感觉。你知道它会很可怕，很多人都这么说。但没人能真正告诉你是什么感受，每个人的经历都完全不同。这就像你别无选择，只能去做。它注定会发生。我觉得这次也一样。这就是一种惯性，它会发生，我只能去做。这很吓人，但我得去做。
My room looks like you could wash it down with a hose, like a vet's examining room. It's an awful mustardy yellow. It overlooks a graveyard. I'm here for five days while they pour deadly medicines into my veins.
我的房间看起来像能用软管冲洗一样，像兽医检查室。那种糟糕的芥末黄色。窗户正对着墓地。我要在这里待五天，他们会把致命的药物注入我的静脉。
I would say in the next four days or so, about three to four days from now, she's going to feel pretty sick to her stomach and maybe have some lose stools and some mouth sores developing once all this chemo builds up in her system.
我想在接下来的四天左右，从现在起大约三四天后，她会感到胃部非常难受，可能会腹泻，并且因为化疗在系统中的积聚而产生口腔溃疡。
Everybody have fun tonight. Everybody--
祝大家今晚玩得开心。大家——
--Wang Chung tonight.
——王中组合（Wang Chung）今晚表演。
Everybody have fun tonight.
祝大家今晚玩得开心。
In the hospital, there's the official information that the staff doles out, and there's the unofficial grapevine, tips and advice that patients share with each other. From the veteran patients, I hear that the University of Nebraska Medical Center doesn't like to give out Zofran, an anti-nausea drug that's very expensive but works like a charm when you're getting chemotherapy. So I start to insist on it to everyone I see. I tell the nurses--
在医院里，有医护人员分发的官方信息，也有非官方的“小道消息”，即病人之间分享的建议。从资深病友那儿，我听说内布拉斯加大学医学中心不喜欢开“枢丹”（Zofran），这是一种很贵但在化疗时效果极好的止吐药。所以我开始坚持向我看到的每个人索要。我告诉护士——
I'd like to have Zofran because that's worked for me in the past.
我想用枢丹，因为它过去对我有效。
--the resident--
——住院医生——
But I really do want Zofran, because I know that works for me.
但我真的想要枢丹，因为我知道它对我有效。
--and the head doctor.
——还有主任医生。
I just feel like I've said this to so many people so many times. I want to get Zofran every day.
我只是觉得我已经对很多人说过很多次了。我每天都想要枢丹。
Despite my requests, my demands, my begging, the first night, they fail to give me Zofran, and like Graham, my jaw stiffens up, a side effect of a cheaper, less effective anti-nausea drug. It's a reminder of what it means to be a patient. You can ask, but sometimes you have very little power.
尽管我请求、要求甚至恳求，第一晚他们还是没给我枢丹，像格雷厄姆一样，我的下巴僵住了，这是那种更便宜、效果较差的止吐药的副作用。这提醒着我“当病人”意味着什么。你可以请求，但有时你几乎没有任何话语权。
During my high dose chemo, I find out that Graham is back in the hospital on a ventilator. They think he has pneumonia and sepsis, an infection of the blood that is common in hospitals and quite serious for transplant patients. Tom and Dan keep giving me updates about Graham's condition, but I don't really want to know.
在大剂量化疗期间，我发现格雷厄姆又被送进了重症监护室戴上了呼吸机。他们认为他患上了肺炎和败血症，这是医院里常见的、对移植病人来说相当严重的一种血液感染。汤姆和丹一直向我更新格雷厄姆的情况，但我其实不想知道。
I kind of like to be a little bit removed from how everybody else is doing.
我喜欢让自己与其他人现在的状况稍微隔绝一点。
Why?
为什么？
Because it's scary. It's hard for me to hear every detail of how everyone else is doing because all that could be happening to me.
因为那很吓人。很难听到别人经历的所有细节，因为所有那些事都有可能发生在我身上。
The staff really did try to help me cope, and I did appreciate how genuinely nice Midwesterners are. But sometimes I just couldn't get with the program.
医护人员确实努力帮我应对，我确实很感激中西部人那种真诚的友好。但有时我就是无法配合。
Twice, rabbis came into my room and left their business card, and told me if I ever wanted to talk. And it was very awkward because they were there to sort of try to, solicit important things out of me about how I was feeling. And I just didn't want to have any part of it. They kept asking me-- the social worker, when I first went into the hospital, she would say, well, are you involved in any religion? And I'd say, no. And then she would say, well, I don't mean organized religion but just your own spirituality. And I'd say, no. And she'd say, well, what about some sort of mystical or some other culture? Are you involved in-- No. I was just sort of no, no, no to all her questions. And I think she didn't know exactly what to make of that because I don't think almost anybody had ever said, no, no, no to all her questions.
两次，拉比来到我的房间留下名片，说如果我想聊聊的话。这非常尴尬，因为他们试图索要我的感受等重要信息。但我一点也不想参与。他们一直问我——社会工作者在我刚进医院时就问，你有什么宗教信仰吗？我说没有。她说，我不是说有组织的宗教，而是指你自己的灵性。我说没有。她又说，那神秘主义或其他文化呢？你参与过吗……不。我对她所有的提问都说“不”。我想她不知道该怎么处理这种情况，因为我想几乎没人对她所有的问题都拒绝。
What worked for me was to work. One of the reasons I wanted to do this documentary was to have a distraction. It was a way to think of myself as a journalist, a working person, as opposed to somebody who was going through a really terrible, grueling medical ordeal. As a reporter, I had learned to be skeptical about medical breakthroughs and miracles, but as a patient, I had to be a believer. So I put my faith in the science, the numbers, the statistics. And for support, I had Tom, who I call [? Zuli, ?] and he was a huge comfort to me.
对我管用的是——工作。我想要拍这部纪录片的原因之一就是为了有个分散注意力的事。这是一种让我把自己视为一名记者、一个忙碌的人的方法，而不是一个正在经历可怕、残酷医疗磨难的人。作为一名记者，我学会了对医学突破和奇迹持怀疑态度，但作为一名病人，我必须成为信徒。所以我把信仰寄托在科学、数字和统计数据上。而为了支持，我有汤姆，我称他为[？朱莉？]，他是我巨大的慰藉。
Somewhere along the line without saying anything, I think we sort of decided when I got sick or something, we just sort of called a truce or something, each of us did. We almost never fight now. Both of us pretty much kind of let things just slide. If I'm pissed off about something, I just sort of say, oh well. He does the same, I think.
在某个过程中，我们虽然没明说，但我想当我们生病时，我们达成了某种休战。我们现在几乎从不吵架。我们俩基本上都让事情随它去。如果我对某事感到恼火，我只会说，哦，好吧。我想他也是一样。
Of course we did have our moments.
当然，我们也有过摩擦。
If you get upset at me and want me to leave, just tell me to leave.
如果你对我不满想要我走，直接告诉我。
I don't want you to leave, [? Zuli. ?] But this is not about you, so just keep your ego in check.
我不想让你走，[？朱莉？]。但这事不是关于你的，所以管好你的自尊心。
I'm not talking about my ego. Don't sit there and just sulk and glare at me. Just tell me to leave.
我不是在说我的自尊。别坐在那里生闷气、瞪我。直接让我走就行。
All right, I will.
好吧，我会的。
I just kind of want him to take care of me. And I think he really has sort of, in a lot of ways, or he is learning to kind of just put his ego aside and do it, just kind of take care of me. I think it's really hard for him.
我只是希望他照顾我。我想他确实在很多方面正在学会放下自尊，去照顾我。这对他来说真的很难。
She actually said something at that point that was kind of enlightening to me. And that was that maybe she needs somebody to get mad at, to focus her negative or her hostility or her anger about what's happening to her. So that was actually an illuminating moment for me because I can understand that.
她在那时候说的话确实让我有所感触。她说也许她需要一个人来发泄，聚焦她对正在发生的事情的负面情绪、敌意或愤怒。所以那对我来说是一个启发性的时刻，因为我能理解那一点。
January 16. My five days of chemo are over.
1月16日。我五天的化疗结束了。
You hear that beep? Tee. Tee, tee. Tee, tee. Well, anyway, that--
听到那个哔哔声了吗？滴，滴，滴。滴，滴。总之，那个——
May I help you?
我能帮你吗？
Can I have my nurse, please?
能叫我的护士吗，请？
I'll send her in, OK?
我叫她进来，好吗？
That is the last bag of my last day of the last chemo in this hospital and hopefully ever.
那是最后一天、最后一次化疗的最后一袋药，希望以后再也不用了。
[HUMMING]
[哼唱]
January 20. It's a big day for Bill Clinton and for me too. He's being sworn in for his second term. I'm getting my stem cells back. They call it day zero because the recovery starts here. Tom and Dan keep trying to get me to say something profound like, getting my stem cells back is like getting my life back. It's true without these stem cells I would die. The chemo wiped out my body's ability to make blood cells. But I'm feeling too lousy to wax poetic.
1月20日。对克林顿总统来说是个大日子，对我也是。他正在进行第二个任期的宣誓就职。我正在回输我的干细胞。他们称之为“第零天”，因为恢复从这里开始。汤姆和丹一直试图让我说出点深奥的话，比如“找回干细胞就像找回我的生命”。没有这些干细胞我确实会死。化疗摧毁了我身体制造血细胞的能力。但我感觉太糟糕了，没法吟诗作对。
I feel nauseous. My stomach hurts. I don't feel like I want to do this. I feel too rotten.
我感觉恶心。胃疼。我不想做这个。我感觉太差了。
This is just dry ice.
这只是干冰。
It's all very anticlimactic. Kathy brings my stem cells up from the deep freeze in a Playmate cooler like she's ready for a beer at the beach.
一切都很平淡。凯西把我的干细胞从深冷冰柜里用一个Playmate冷藏箱拿了出来，就像准备去海滩喝啤酒一样。
OK, we've got Rebecca B. Perl, 712792. I'll take 75 for the first hour.
好了，我们要处理丽贝卡·B·珀尔，病人编号712792。第一个小时我取75。
She thaws out the bags of stem cells like you would a frozen chicken breast and infuses them back into my body through the catheter.
她像解冻冷冻鸡胸肉一样解冻了那些干细胞，并通过导管输回我的身体。
There they go.
它们进去了。
I'm groggy and half asleep for most of it. When I come to, I hear Clinton.
大部分时间我都在昏昏沉沉中。清醒过来时，我听到了克林顿的声音。
Fellow citizens, we must not waste the precious gift of this time. For all of us are on that same journey of our lives.
各位公民，我们绝不能浪费这段宝贵的时间。因为我们所有人都在各自的人生旅途中。
That night I feel a little better.
那天晚上我感觉好了一点。
I'm feeling well enough to try some Sugar Smacks.
我感觉好些了，想尝尝糖脆麦片。
All right.
好的。
[SINGING] Can't get enough of those Sugar Smacks, Sugar Smacks, Sugar Smacks. Can't get enough of those Sugar Smacks. I could take them home for tea.
[唱歌] 受不了那些糖脆麦片，糖脆麦片，糖脆麦片。我可以带它们回家当茶点。
So remember, all you cancer patients, when you're feeling awful, try Sugar Smacks. Mmm. It's my food of choice.
所以记住，各位癌症病人，当你感觉糟透了的时候，试试糖脆麦片。嗯，这是我的首选食物。
But over the next few days, as the chemo destroys my immune system, I feel as rotten as I've ever felt. This is rock bottom. And without the energy that comes from blood cells, I feel fragile, anxious, and empty.
但在接下来的几天里，当化疗摧毁我的免疫系统时，我感觉到了前所未有的糟糕。这是谷底。没有了血细胞带来的能量，我觉得脆弱、焦虑且空虚。
Well, it's January 21. It's day one, ie I had my transplant yesterday. Is that right? Isn't it day two by now? Gosh, they're going slow. But I feel pretty crappy. I feel very nauseous. And my stomach is just very churny. Today I ate what I was sure I could stomach, a piece of rye bread and some ginger ale, and I even threw that up. But I would like to say it was almost pleasant throwing up ginger ale. It's a lot better than throwing up some other things I could name, like orange juice. Blech.
今天是1月21日。第一天，也就是昨天我做了移植。是吗？现在已经是第二天了吗？天哪，时间过得好慢。我感觉很糟糕。我感到非常恶心。胃里翻江倒海。今天我吃了自认为能消化的黑麦面包和姜汁汽水，结果还是吐了。但我得说，吐姜汁汽水的过程还算愉快。比起吐其他东西，比如橙汁，好多了。呕。
There's some comfort in knowing that I'm supposed to feel this way. The chemo can't distinguish between healthy cells and the cancer, so it wipes out everything that grows fast-- the lining of the digestive tract, the blood cells, hair follicles. One patient who has just been through it assures me it will pass.
知道自己会感觉这样，这本身也是种安慰。化疗无法区分健康细胞和癌细胞，所以它会消灭所有快速生长的细胞——消化道内壁、血细胞、毛囊。一位刚经历过这些的病人向我保证，这会过去的。
I thought I was going to die two days ago, and now I feel like-- like I said, as soon as you think it's never going to end, it does get better. I know how you feel right now.
两天前我觉得自己快死了，现在感觉……正如我所说，一旦你以为永无止境，它就开始变好了。我知道你现在的感受。
Dawn is a couple years older than me and has a 10-year-old. Looking at her is like looking in a mirror.
道恩比我大几岁，有个10岁的孩子。看着她就像照镜子。
Well, and don't you find too that every time you see pictures of your son or whatever, doesn't that make you just even more determined to get better? See, it does me too. Or if I see my daughter, it just makes me more determined.
难道你不觉得吗？每次看到儿子的照片，都会让你更坚定要好起来？看，我也一样。每次看到我女儿，就让我更坚定。
Right, right. Yeah.
是啊，对。
It just makes me more determined. Every time I think, oh, God, I feel so bad. I just don't want to go on. Then I just think, oh, what's Jessica going to do without me? Then it's like, oh, I've got to kick myself in the seat and get with it.
这让我更坚定。每次我想，“噢天呐，我感觉太糟了，不想活了。”然后就想到“如果没了我，杰西卡怎么办？”然后我就像被踢了一脚一样，振作起来。
I feel that way about the whole fight, that I probably wouldn't fight half as hard except for Griffin. Well, what choice do you have, really?
我也觉得整个抗癌过程就是这样，除了为了格里芬，我可能不会这么努力。好吧，你其实有什么选择呢？
You don't.
没有。
I think if my life maybe was different, maybe if there wasn't Tom and Griffin, maybe I would say, I've lived and I've done things, and I just don't want to fight this anymore. I'm tired of it. You know, if you have to keep going through it and going through it. But you can't do that when you have a kid. Or I don't feel like I can do that with a kid. I feel like I have to keep fighting, even though it's a pain in the butt.
我想如果我的生活不同，如果没有汤姆和格里芬，也许我会说，我已经活过，也做过一些事，我不想再抗争了。我累了。你知道，如果不得不一遍又一遍地经历这些。但当你有个孩子时你做不到。或者我觉得有孩子时我无法这样做。我觉得必须继续战斗，尽管这真的很麻烦。
More of Rebecca Perl's story in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
一分钟后，来自公共广播国际台的丽贝卡·珀尔的故事更多精彩内容，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, we bring you a variety of different kinds of stories. Today, we're dedicating our entire program to just one about what it's like to be treated for a life-threatening illness. NPR health sciences reporter Rebecca Perl moved to Omaha for extra intensive chemotherapy and a bone marrow transplant.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目每周都会带来各种故事。今天，我们把全部节目留给一个关于接受危及生命的疾病治疗的故事。NPR健康科学记者丽贝卡·珀尔搬到奥马哈进行高强度化疗和骨髓移植。
Do you have any discomfort when you sit forward?
你向前坐时感到不适吗？
No, I just feel a little shaky. I'm not sure if it's real or just fear.
不，我只是感到有点颤抖。我不确定是真实的还是恐惧导致的。
Though my recovery was supposed to be outpatient, two days after the transplant, I'm back in the hospital.
虽然我的恢复被安排在门诊进行，但在移植两天后，我又回到了医院。
Well, it's day three. And I'm here because last night at about 11 o'clock, I noticed that my heart was beating so fast that when I was laying on the bed, I'd just feel it going thump-thump, thump-thump, thump-thump, thump-thump, thump-thump, thump-thump thump-thump.
现在是第三天。我在这里是因为昨晚11点左右，我注意到我的心脏跳得飞快，躺在床上时，我就感觉到它跳个不停——咚咚，咚咚，咚咚。
It was beating really fast. Dun-dun, dun-dun, dun-dun. And I counted like 150 or 160. Her normal is eighty. I said, OK, get dressed. Let's go.
它跳得真的很快。咚咚，咚咚，咚咚。我数了一下，大概是150或160次。她正常是80次。我说，好了，穿上衣服。我们走。
So I just kind of got out of bed and started to come in. And I sat down on a chair in the living room for a minute, but I must have fallen over because the next thing I knew I was on the floor.
于是我从床上起来，试图走出来。我在客厅的椅子上坐了一会儿，但一定是我摔倒了，因为下一刻我发现自己在地板上。
And then I heard a thud. And I came running out. And Bec was spread eagle on her back, just flat on her back, staring up. And I went and looked in her face, looked in her eyes. And she wasn't registering. And I said, Bec, Bec, can you hear me? Bec. And she just didn't register me. Her eyes were blank. And I was just scared [BLEEP] that something had really happened, like she had had a heart attack or a stroke or something. And then within a couple seconds, she came back. And she registered me.
然后我听到“砰”的一声，跑了出来。贝卡大字型躺在背上，盯着上方。我走过去看她的脸，看她的眼睛。她没有任何反应。我说，贝卡，贝卡，听得见我吗？贝卡。她就是没反应。她的眼神是空洞的。我吓坏了，以为真的发生了什么事，比如心脏病发作或中风。然后几秒钟内，她恢复了，看向我。
And then we walked out to the car. And then we drove pretty quickly to the hospital. And suddenly there were like a million nurses and PAs and internal medicine guys all in here hooking me up to these monitors and seeing what was going on with my heart. And it was beating at like 190. But the thing that stopped it was they gave me this weird drug which they just put into your catheter, and it makes your heart stop for like three seconds. And it was a weird, unpleasant feeling, kind of like an electrical feeling right after it, just like electricity going through your body or something. And I felt really weird. And I still think I feel a little weird from that. But that got my heart rate down to like normal, to like 120.
我们走到车里，迅速开车赶往医院。突然，上百万名护士、医师助理和内科医生都在这里，把我连上显示器监测心脏。它跳动频率大约是190。但停止它的方式是他们给了我一种奇怪的药物，直接推入导管，那会让你的心脏停跳大约三秒钟。那是一种奇怪、不舒服的感觉，之后有一种电流感，就像有电穿过你的身体一样。我感觉真的很奇怪。我至今还觉得受了影响。但那让我的心率降到了正常的120左右。
Hi, I just stopped by to tell you the results of the ECHO. And I think you already know. There was no fluid around the heart. The valves are normal. The heart function normal.
嗨，我来告诉你超声心动图的结果。我想你已经知道了。心脏周围没有积液。瓣膜正常，功能正常。
And then by the end of the day, Dr. [? Taryntula ?] comes in, who's a great guy, a sweet guy. And he says, I don't know what problem is. We may never know. Let's just hope it doesn't happen again. And that's where we have left it. And that's completely unsatisfying, you know?
然后到了傍晚，[？塔兰图拉？]医生进来了，他是个很棒、很贴心的人。他说，我不知道问题出在哪里。我们可能永远不会知道。让我们祈祷它别再发生。这就是我们得到的结论。这完全无法令人满意，你知道吗？
So they don't know. We don't know. They're not even going to treat it, really. I think I'd feel better if they sort of thought it was something and could treat it. You always think medicine is going to be like that, like you'll find the answer and that will be that. But a lot of times you just don't. We're no closer to knowing what the problem is than when we started out, really, except that they think everything's OK. They think it's behind us, and we're not really going to treat it. But I don't know why my heart was racing like that. It was scary.
所以他们不知道。我们也不知道。他们甚至没法真正治疗它。我想如果他们认定是某种问题并且能治疗，我会好受些。你总认为医学会是那样，你会找到答案，事情就会解决。但很多时候你就是找不到。我们和开始时一样一无所知，只不过他们认为一切都还好。他们认为事情已经过去了，不再进行治疗。但我不知道为什么我的心会跳得那么快。那很吓人。
That has stayed with me in a way that nothing else has because it's like losing your innocence or something. I mean, it just seems like this weird thing. My heart isn't supposed to ever stop, and my heart has been stopped. And to me, that represents some sort of loss of innocence, something that just should have never happened. And it sits badly with me. It's almost like everything else is OK, but that really gets me somehow. I wish that hadn't happened.
那件事一直困扰着我，因为那就像是失去了纯真。我的意思是，那看起来太奇怪了。我的心脏本不该停止跳动，而它确实停过。对我来说，那代表了某种纯真的丧失，某种本不该发生的事。这让我感觉很糟。就像一切都好，但那件事不知为何让我耿耿于怀。我真希望没发生过。
So if we can treat this and get it under control, get the virus gone before your white cells return, then that's the best way to do it.
所以如果我们在白细胞恢复之前能治疗并控制住它，清除病毒，那就是最好的方式。
Four days after the transplant, and I'm about to go home to our apartment. I'm busy worrying about Tom having to give me antibiotic injections at home, except I don't have to worry about that because they tell me I have something called RSV.
移植四天后，我准备回家。我正忙着担心汤姆在家给我打抗生素注射液，但我不需要担心了，因为他们告诉我我患上了RSV（呼吸道合胞病毒）。
So you won't be getting out of here today, unfortunately. We really need to treat this.
所以很不幸，你今天不能出院了。我们确实需要治疗这个。
For like a week?
要一周吗？
For a week. OK?
一周。好吗？
The treatment requires I stay in the hospital isolation room for a week. And for 18 hours a day, I have to wear this ridiculous-looking and very uncomfortable mask strapped to my face so I can breathe in an aerosol medicine. Here's something that people forget. It's not just physically grueling being sick. It's boring.
治疗要求我在隔离病房待一周。每天18个小时，我必须戴着这个看起来很荒谬且非常不舒服的面罩，才能吸入雾化药物。这是人们常忽略的一点：生病不仅是生理上的煎熬，而且很无聊。
It feels tight around my nose. And it feels sort of stuffy. And it just feels like it's hard to sleep in because it's big, and I feel kind of like an elephant or something with this big nose. I can't eat with it on or do anything. I just feel like I have to stay very still. Watching TV is good.
鼻子周围感觉很紧，很闷。戴着它睡觉很难受，因为它很大，我感觉自己像头大象。戴着它没法吃东西或做别的事。我感觉必须保持静止。看电视还不错。
Would you like a cup of coffee?
想来杯咖啡吗？
What time is it?
现在几点了？
About 1:30.
一点半左右。
1:30? I must get dressed and go.
一点半？我必须穿上衣服走了。
Why? What's your hurry? There's lots of time.
为什么？你急什么？时间还早着呢。
Oh, no, there isn't. And I've been quite enough trouble to you as it is.
噢，不，不早了。而且我给你添了够多麻烦了。
Trouble? You're not what I'd call trouble.
麻烦？你那可不叫麻烦。
That was just miserable because I had to be on this machine for 18 hours for seven days. And I think my overall feeling about that was I was just embarrassed to be stuck with that thing on my face. I couldn't even believe it was happening to me. And also, I was mad. I was mad that they were doing this to me. At one point, the doctor said to me, hey, we're not doing this to you to be mean. He had to kind of remind me. And I mean, I knew that, but I was pissed that they were doing this to me. But that anger kept me from being worried or scared, because their fear was that my lungs were going to clog up with this RSV virus and I would get something similar to pneumonia or I wouldn't be able to breathe.
那段日子真悲惨，因为我得七天里有18个小时连着那台机器。我总的感受是，脸上贴着那东西真的感到很尴尬。我简直不敢相信这发生在我身上。而且我很愤怒，愤怒他们对我做这些。有一次，医生跟我说，嘿，我们做这些不是为了对你刻薄。他不得不提醒我。我知道那点，但我很生气。但那种愤怒让我无暇担心或恐惧，因为他们最担心的是我的肺会被病毒堵住，产生类似肺炎的情况或者无法呼吸。
[FLUTE MUSIC PLAYING]
[长笛音乐响起]
Just down the hall, Graham has been on a respirator for more than a week. After Graham's 8-year-old old daughter, Kelli, plays her flute for him, he seems to show some slight improvement, but the doctors say he's still in critical condition.
就在走廊的那头，格雷厄姆戴着呼吸机已经超过一周了。在格雷厄姆8岁的女儿凯莉为他吹奏长笛后，他看起来有了一点好转，但医生说他仍处于危重状态。
It was a disconnect for me. I just didn't make the connection that there were all these other people on respirators, and I could easily be one of them in a matter of days. I didn't think it was going to happen.
那对我来说是一种隔阂。我就是没意识到还有这么多人在戴呼吸机，而我几天之内很轻易就可能成为其中之一。我不认为那会发生。
The big question that we're completely avoiding-- and, in fact, I haven't even thought about it until this point, really-- is the cancer itself. We're in the midst of this whole process right now. And you're so encumbered with the daily routine and sucking aerosol and getting your counts done. And so you're totally drawn into the process, and you're not really thinking about the final goal at all. The cancer, we know that it's there. We're here for that. But we're not thinking about that at all. I'm not, anyhow.
我们完全避开的一个大问题——事实上，直到此刻我才真正想到它——就是癌症本身。我们正身处整个过程中。你被日常琐事所困，吸入气溶胶、检测血象。你完全被卷入了这个过程，根本没在想最终目标。我们知道癌症在那儿，我们就是为此而来的。但我根本没想过那个。至少我没想。
You did it. Yeah. Now it's just tidying things up. That's really a huge thing, really big.
你做到了。是的。现在只是扫尾工作。这真的很了不起，非常了不起。
Finally a piece of good news. Dr. Armitage, the head of the Omaha transplant program, drops by my room to tell me that the stem cells they transplanted into me are growing new cells.
终于有个好消息。奥马哈移植项目的负责人阿米蒂奇医生来到我房间，告诉我移植给我的干细胞正在生长出新细胞。
Knowing that you have an adequate granulocyte count that you made yourself means you've engrafted. The marrow took. You're no longer at risk of sudden lethal infections. That means you've leaped over one other big barrier. And in fact, the truth is, usually, from now on, things are downhill.
知道你自己拥有足够的粒细胞计数意味着你已经成功植入了。骨髓接纳了。你不再处于突然致命感染的风险中。这意味着你跨过了一个巨大的障碍。事实上，通常从现在开始，一切都会好起来。
It was really nice and reassuring to have him say that because we had had a sort of a small setback, where I had had more chemo, and when we looked at the tests, that chemo hadn't done anything to shrink the tumor. And so you worry that the bone marrow transplant isn't even going to work. And he said, really without any information, I'm very pleased with how everything went, with this undertone of, you've probably made it. It's probably worked. You're probably OK. I don't know how he would have known that, or maybe he was bluffing. But it was real reassuring to have him come and say those things.
听他这么说真的很让人宽慰，因为我们经历了一次小挫折，我又多做了化疗。当我们看检查结果时，那些化疗没能让肿瘤缩小。所以你会担心骨髓移植甚至都不会有效。而他说，即便没有确切数据，他也对我所经历的一切非常满意，暗示着“你可能挺过来了，可能有效，你可能没问题”。我不知道他怎么会知道这些，或者也许他是在虚张声势。但能听到他说这些话确实非常让人安心。
And your blood counts are looking great. Wonderful platelets. I don't know if you saw them today.
而且你的血象看起来很棒。很棒的血小板。不知道你今天看没看。
Day 11. They've just let me out of the hospital, and all of a sudden, it's over. Just as sure as I was locked away, they're going to let me go.
第11天。他们刚让我出院，突然间，一切都结束了。正如我被锁在里面一样，他们终于要放我走了。
What do you say about getting your catheter out and getting home? How's that sound?
拆掉导管回家，你觉得怎么样？
Yeah.
嗯。
Up for that? Congratulations.
准备好了吗？祝贺你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
We just need to give you a nice little certificate saying you're out of here. No. You did a great job.
我们需要给你发一张证明，说你可以离开了。不，你做得很好。
It was weird to me when they said, OK, you can go home. And congratulations. Yay! And everybody clapped and kissed and hugged.
当他们说“好的，你可以回家了，恭喜！耶！”时，我感到很奇怪。大家鼓掌、亲吻、拥抱。
I'm so thrilled for you.
真为你高兴。
Yeah. Thanks for helping.
是啊，谢谢你的帮助。
Oh, hey.
噢，嘿。
I was like, wait a second. I haven't won anything here. We don't know whether this worked. We know I got through this, but that's little consolation. The really big prize here, the car, the trip to Hawaii, is did the cancer go away? And we didn't know, and we weren't going to know for months. And so it was all very weird, everybody congratulating you and patting you on the back and saying good for you and hey, it's all over now. It seemed very strange to me.
我当时想，等一下。我赢了什么了吗？我们不知道这是否有效。我们知道我熬过来了，但这没多少安慰。真正的大奖，那辆车、那趟夏威夷之旅，是癌症真的消失了吗？我们不知道，几个月内也不会知道。所以那一切都很奇怪，每个人都在恭喜你、拍你的背，说你做的好，说一切都结束了。对我来说这显得很诡异。
You're a doll. You take it easy. We'll see you when you come back in 100 days. Bye.
你真是个宝贝。放轻松。100天后复查时再见。再见。
For the first couple weeks I was in Omaha, I felt like I was on an assembly line. You come in through a revolving door. You get on the line. You get your catheter. You get your stem cells removed. You get your high dose chemo. You get your stem cells back. So now I was leaving, walking fast, head up. Suddenly I was the veteran, the old pro. And there was a scared old man with his family who had just arrived for his transplant, looking shaky and small as he sat huddled by the door.
在奥马哈的前几周，我觉得自己像是在流水线上。你穿过旋转门。你走上这条路。装上导管。取出干细胞。做大剂量化疗。回输干细胞。现在我要离开了，快步走着，昂着头。突然我成了资深人士，老手了。有个带着家人刚到的惊恐的老人，坐在门口，缩成一团，看起来摇摇欲坠。
You don't feel too good, but, you know, at least it goes by pretty-- what's good is the white cells come back pretty fast, so just a matter of about 10 days there where you're really vulnerable.
你感觉不会太好，但你知道，至少它过得很快……好在白细胞恢复得很快，所以大概有10天时间你真的会很脆弱。
Then we say goodbye to Lorraine.
然后我们要和洛林说再见了。
How's Graham doing?
格雷厄姆怎么样了？
Her husband, Graham, is still on a respirator. She tells us that she's losing hope.
她的丈夫格雷厄姆还在戴呼吸机。她告诉我们她正在失去希望。
It's starting to feel like it's not going to work. Sorry.
感觉好像没用了。抱歉。
No. Don't worry. Forget it. Lorraine.
别担心。忘掉它。洛林。
I tell her to be optimistic, but I don't know why I'm saying this. In my heart, I know she's right to prepare herself for Graham's death. It's not a good scene. Here I am leaving, getting out of town alive, and Lorraine's world is falling apart. I feel terrible for her, but mostly I want to get the hell out of here. I want to run. Still I hug her, and I tell her not to lose hope.
我告诉她要乐观，但我不知道为什么这么说。我内心深处知道，她准备接受格雷厄姆的离世是对的。这不是个好场面。我正要离开，活着逃出这座城，而洛林的世界正在崩塌。我为她感到难过，但我最想做的就是逃离这里。我想跑。但我还是抱了抱她，告诉她不要失去希望。
That's pretty scary. That's pretty scary. It's early for that still. It's early, though, for that.
那很吓人。那很吓人。现在说这个还太早。太早了。
I have a weird sense of this whole thing with Graham because, I mean, well, now it looks bad for Graham. But for a while there I was thinking he could pull through and make it and the bone marrow transplant wouldn't really work for me. And I could be down, and he could be up. And I mean, nothing's guaranteed here at all.
我对格雷厄姆的事有一种奇怪的感觉，因为，嗯，现在对他来说情况看起来很糟。但有一阵子我还在想，他能挺过来，而骨髓移植对我可能没用。可能他活下来而我倒下。没人能保证什么。
Bye, Lorraine. We'll call you. Yeah. We'll call you.
再见，洛林。我们会给你打电话的。是的，我们会打。
OK.
好的。
Take care. Give Graham a kiss for us. Can you get in there to kiss him? OK. Then do. Bye. Bye, Thomas. Bye, Thomas! Say hi to Kelli.
保重。替我们亲吻格雷厄姆。你能进去亲他吗？那好。再见。再见，托马斯。再见，托马斯！向凯莉问好。
Griffy, you've gotten so big. I'm sorry I had to be away for so long. I was away, but I'm back now. Are you my Griffy? Are you my Griffy?
格里芬，你长这么大了。对不起，妈妈离开了这么久。妈妈走开了，但现在回来了。你是我的格里芬吗？你是我的格里芬吗？
I want to believe, and I think I basically do believe that this whole ordeal did not impact Griffy in a bad way. And I think that it didn't.
我想相信，我也基本相信，整个折磨并没有对格里芬产生坏的影响。我觉得确实没有。
Mommy.
妈妈。
Mommy came back. "'Mommy,' they cried. They flapped and they danced and they bounced up and down on their branches. 'What's all the fuss,' their mother owl said. 'You knew I'd come back.' And the baby owls thought-- because all owls think a lot. 'I knew it,' said Sarah. 'And I knew it,' said Percy. 'I love my mommy,' said Bill."
妈妈回来了。“妈妈，”它们喊道。它们拍打着，跳着舞，在树枝上跳上跳下。“有什么好大惊小怪的，”猫头鹰妈妈说，“你们知道我会回来的。”而猫头鹰宝宝想——因为猫头鹰想得很多。“我就知道，”莎拉说。“我就知道，”珀西说。“我爱我的妈妈，”比尔说。
Griffy.
格里芬。
Mommy.
妈妈。
Griffy.
格里芬。
Mommy.
妈妈。
Griffy.
格里芬。
Mommy.
妈妈。
And Mommy.
还有妈妈。
Mommy.
妈妈。
Hi, is this the seventh floor bone marrow transplant unit? I was trying to reach Lorraine Brazier. I'm a friend of hers, and I was on the unit myself. Rebecca Perl. And I was just trying to find out about Graham. He's not in the room anymore.
嗨，是七楼骨髓移植病房吗？我试图联系洛林·布拉泽尔。我是她的朋友，我自己也曾在那个病房。丽贝卡·珀尔。我只是想打听一下格雷厄姆。他不在房间里了。
February 3. I've been home four days when I call back to Omaha to see how Graham is doing.
2月3日。我回家四天了，我打回奥马哈询问格雷厄姆的情况。
This morning. Did they just take him off the respirator? They didn't. He just-- he wasn't breathing. Oh. Oh, gosh.
今天早上。他们刚拔掉呼吸机吗？没有。他只是……他没呼吸了。噢，天呐。
So weird. I mean, this isn't what you expect, you know? I mean, it's rare that people die from the bone marrow transplant, but I guess it happens. But it's rare when you get your own cells. I don't know. I just feel sorry for Lorraine. Because she's got two little kids. One is just one year old, and one is eight years old. That's a lot. And it's just a lot that they won't have a father.
太奇怪了。这不是你能预料到的，你知道吗？骨髓移植导致死亡很罕见，但我想也会发生。使用自己的干细胞时更罕见。我不知道。我只是为洛林感到难过，因为她有两个小孩。一个才一岁，一个八岁。那太多了。他们没有了父亲，这太沉重了。
Springtime. The buds on the maple tree outside our bedroom window have begun to sprout, and so has my hair. I call this tree my hair tree because since I've been having chemo, my hair has fallen out and grown back at the same time the tree has lost its leaves and sprouted new ones.
春天到了。我们卧室窗外的枫树芽开始萌发，我的头发也一样。我把这棵树称为“头发树”，因为自从化疗以来，我的头发掉了，又长出来，正如树木落叶又萌发新芽一样。
Welcome to Omaha's Eppley Airfield. The terminal curb is for the immediate loading and unloading of passengers.
欢迎来到奥马哈埃普利机场。航站楼路边仅供旅客即停即走。
April 15. Three months have gone by, and we're back in Omaha. It's tax day and the day I find out if my transplant worked. This time we're only here for two days, and Griffin is with us.
4月15日。三个月过去了，我们又回到了奥马哈。今天是报税日，也是我得知移植是否有效的那天。这次我们只待两天，格里芬也和我们在一起。
That's Dr. Vose.
那是沃斯医生。
Who is this?
这是谁？
That's Griffin.
那是格里芬。
How you doing? You taking good care of mom?
你好吗？有好好照顾妈妈吗？
The news is good. Dr. Vose tells us the tumor has shrunk significantly.
新闻是好消息。沃斯医生告诉我们肿瘤显著缩小了。
CAT scan looked really good. They said that the mass was shrinking from where it was. Last time we checked in, it was two by one. That's pretty close to being what we would consider normal size for a lymph node. So it's definitely a lot smaller. It's hard to know for sure if it's completely gone.
CT扫描看起来很不错。他们说肿块比之前缩小了。上次我们检查时是2乘以1。这非常接近我们认为的淋巴结正常大小。所以它确实小了很多。很难确认是否完全消失。
It's definitely not smaller?
真的没缩小吗？
A lot smaller. A lot smaller.
小了很多。小了很多。
Oh, OK. Well, that's good. Yeah, thank you.
噢，好吧。那是好消息。是的，谢谢。
Yeah, well, you did all the work.
是啊，都是你自己的功劳。
I think we got about as good news as we could. I mean, it could shrink a little bit more, I suppose. And it's possible that what we're seeing, the reason it's somewhat bigger than a regular lymph node is that there's scar tissue. So hopefully that's what it is and we're OK. And so that's nice. It's good. This is the part where we do the Mary Tyler Moore, like take off hat and throw it up in the air. We need that music. [SINGING] You might just make it after all.
我想我们得到了最好的消息。它可以再缩小一点。它现在看起来比普通淋巴结稍大，可能是因为那是疤痕组织。希望确实如此。这很好。我们要像《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》那样把帽子扔向天空。我们需要那段音乐。[唱歌] 你可能终将成功。
It's funny when you realize you're going to get your life back, that your job isn't just fighting a disease anymore. Suddenly you have to live. Egad. You can't just sit around and wait to be better. You've got to go back to work or at least do something. Study biology, write a book. That was very strange and difficult for me at first, because for the past year and a half, I'd been doing very little. Reading, resting, looking through catalogs. I was scared to go back to work, to face getting dressed every day, to be busy, on deadline, frantic, to let my orderly life and my time with Griffin get away from me.
当你意识到自己要找回生命，意识到你的工作不再只是抗癌时，这很有趣。突然你必须去生活。哎呀。你不能只是坐着等好起来。你必须回去工作或者至少做点什么。学习生物，写本书。起初这对我来说既奇怪又困难，因为过去一年半，我什么都没做。读书、休息、翻目录。我害怕回去工作，害怕面对每天穿衣，害怕忙碌、赶期限，害怕被打乱的生活和陪格里芬的时间溜走。
One year since my transplant. The tumor has shrunk to the size of a normal lymph node, suggesting the disease is gone. I'm back at work, but my energy is still low. I'm tired a lot, and when Griffin gets sick with a cold, I get sick too. And I get it bad. Still, we go on vacation. Tom and I went to Rome this fall. We see friends, make dinner. We even fight. And though my life is pretty good, I don't feel ecstatic, but I feel content. And if I worry, I worry about life returning to the way it was before I got sick.
移植一周年。肿瘤已经缩小到正常淋巴结大小，意味着疾病可能已经消失。我回到了工作岗位，但精力仍然不足。我常感到累，格里芬感冒时我也跟着感冒，而且会很严重。即便如此，我们还是去度假。汤姆和我在秋天去了罗马。我们见朋友，做饭。甚至吵架。虽然我的生活相当不错，我没感到狂喜，但感到满足。如果我担心什么，那就是担心生活恢复到我生病前的样子。
Sometimes, I think, I wonder if it changed me. You know, like Armitage, who's the head doctor in Omaha, said, you don't go through this without changing. And sometimes I feel like I'm really just the same. I still sweat the little details or get mad if the kitchen is a mess or something, things that shouldn't matter to me anymore having gone through something like this. And yet I still get caught up in them. And so sometimes I think I haven't changed. And that scares me because it makes me think that if I haven't changed, then I do everything the same, then I could get sick again. But if I can learn from this and change, then I won't.
有时我想，我不知道这是否改变了我。阿米蒂奇医生说过，经历这些不可能不改变。有时我觉得自己还是老样子。我依然纠结于琐事，如果厨房乱七八糟还是会生气，这些在经历过这些之后本不该困扰我的事。然而我依然会被它们困住。有时我觉得自己没变。那很吓人，因为那意味着如果我没变，那我就可能重蹈覆辙再次生病。但如果我能从中吸取教训并改变，那我就不会了。
Scenes From a Transplant was produced by Dan Collison with help from Tom Jennings, to whom this story is dedicated. The story was originally shot on video. Dan Collison is currently looking for funding for a video version of the documentary. Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett and [? Sahini ?] Davenport.
《移植的场景》由丹·科利森制作，汤姆·詹宁斯协助，本故事献给他。故事最初用视频拍摄。丹·科利森目前正在为这部纪录片的视频版本寻求资金。今天我们的节目由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德协助。资深编辑保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、马吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。劳拉·多格特和[？萨希尼？]达文波特提供制作帮助。
This week we are pleased to announce that This American Life now has a website on the internet. The address, www.thislife.org. That's thislife, one word, no space in between this and life. www.thislife.org. On the site, you'll find sound files of most of our programs to listen to whenever you wish. Thanks to Elizabeth Wasserman and KCRW. If you'd like to buy an old-fashioned cassette of our program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago, 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected]
本周我们很高兴宣布《美国生活》现在有了网站。地址是www.thislife.org。记住，thislife是一个词，中间没有空格。在网站上，你可以找到我们大多数节目的音频文件随时收听。感谢伊丽莎白·瓦瑟曼和KCRW。如果你想购买我们节目的老式磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。电子邮箱：[email protected]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ管理层监督是托里·马拉蒂亚。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际台。